hey what's up guys
Tuesday destiny day reset Destiny's
children episode 2 this week I have John
Luke he was busy last week but like we
said we kind of rotate between me John
Luke and Rob here in the u.s. Friday's
the UK team two more Lucy and Dave
they'll be posting up a video long play
of their adventures in destiny 2 we do
Tuesday live streams for the reset so
mainly going to focus on the nightfall
obviously today as well as kind of just
going through our weekly stuff like the
all the stuff reset our clans level 3
now check out my sick new raid armor yes
you finished the raid which is awesome I
also finished a raid I got a raid armor
as well but we're just gonna primarily
be on John Luke speed but if he sees me
later you'll see that I have like two
pieces on so fun times hopefully you
guys are able to do the right if now
hopefully you guys are able to do it
this week the fun fact about the raid is
if you did it last week it I'll turn up
the mics if you did the rail ass tweak
it's slightly different this week as I
mentioned to you just in terms of the
order of which you do the raid so this
week it's the Pleasure Gardens then the
gauntlet then the the bathers or the the
baths the pools so they're just kind of
mixing it up for you to at least change
up your mindset a little bit I guess
maybe since it's week two I think that's
kind of cool range it up to not have it
be like the same exact way that makes
the way that raids designed
hopefully the mics are better now I
turned it up a bit I heard a couple
people complaining about low audio but
hopefully we're good now and so yeah we
stream Destiny's children every two are
sorry every week at 11:00 and then
before okay folks we'll be handling a
destiny show join Friday so tune in to
that make sure you guys are subbed for
that just check that stuff out so
gentleman still kind of running through
the tower kind of figuring out his
loadout the interesting thing about the
nightfall is even though it doesn't save
prism it might have prism on it which is
that elemental modifier so of course if
that does have it we're gonna want to
try to you know ensure that we have our
elements I got a change I'm gonna go
quickly grab the yeah so someone in our
clan lovely already did that finished
our clan PvP this week just so now you
get a powerful Engram hopefully you got
something good I got an exotic from
which is lucky chance and so you could
potentially get one did not
unfortunately so actually sorry that
sorry I my Hawthorne one was from
personal clan XP that's how I got my
he's on yes I think it's like you it's
related yeah the thing so I'm gonna get
crucible related weapons yeah I got a
better Devils like I got I got this a
couple of rocket launcher from the raid
clan yeah because you get it related and
you got the trial I got the trial 29
into trials cool so when you're ready
you can join yeah my friend my other
buddy in the game socks I am just gonna
be with us so we'll see how that goes
all right it's good we're also trying to
monitor chat to the best of our ability
will see it in front of us when earlier
saying rip PC version I don't know what
you're talking about so yeah dude it's
gonna be good there's gonna be a lot of
people playing you're gonna like there's
gonna be some people I feel like that
are gonna play both they're gonna go
from like console to PC they're kind of
just playing this now until PC right so
that is all of my friends are pretty
much doing that like yeah I know most of
them are all gonna switch to PC once it
comes out
and so actually like now it's kind of
the point where okay it's been two weeks
I've beaten the raid now it's just kind
of more into like the grind right like
the the rhythm yeah and so the question
is do I want to heavily invest in this
rhythm or do I just kind of want to like
really hold off and wait for the PC
version and make that my main rhythm so
I'm probably only gonna play destiny now
like once a week kind of like this sort
of stuff like I'll know do the nightfall
do do some crucible you know get my get
my clan stuff probably won't rate every
week but maybe every once in a while
depending on you know if I have like
much friends who want to do it but it's
not gonna like heavily invest in destiny
going forward and going forward until
the PC version sell and then I'll kind
of figure out what I want to do even
though my boy plugged into my controller
which is not very good so I'm gonna try
to figure that out in the meantime you
can cut it so can you increase the
output volume okay the output volume
general gameplay or our mics cuz the
mics for the most part I have max says
you might stick to ps4 cuz more
clanmates there yeah that's a good point
I mean a lot of its gonna depend on on
people so anomaly is detected you can
start looking for some of these things
just shoot I don't know if they're
around it but basically the way to gain
time this week is to shoot these said oh
I see one anomalies that's good so also
there's light little like pools of light
that you can pick up now to gain health
and super Oh
they basically look like Dadar oh I
immediately got run over okay it's
really just what I'm trying to think of
like way to do this start over
no no so those things are not the things
we need a shoot no but we need to do
these - yeah I'm thinking like oh
there's one right here
oh okay did you get killed by a prank no
I don't think so look like prisms turned
off so anyone that was doing the night
ball earlier had that weird like 3/3
modifier but now it looks like it's just
attrition and anomalies or the time
bonus we need to find more of these
anomalies oh yeah policy only found the
one and you said you found one I found
one yeah that I killed change they're
gone
oh wait no it's back
no they're just in different locations
it's just anomalies right yeah there's
just some weird spots about timewarps I
just saw no no that's about
whoa aah sniper I'm still looking
how far back okay you're back what
that's pretty cool this is the no one
else can see it from the raid ghost
Primus you can inspect me to see oh
there's an another anomaly oh you got
can you get him up get him up
oh boy this year's kind of more generous
than last week with time wise cuz yeah I
know this this nightfall is longer and
less oh you get it you know the boss is
um let's the promise a lot harder right
for some reason everything hits harder
but no oh I got sniped there's alright
that's what got me okay hi Jesus
okay quality video content
you know first first time do it yeah
then I have no way to kill this guy
because Scout which I will switch to cuz
nameless might nameless midnight rules
all
Oh Travis boys they're still anomaly
somewhere
has haunted us he's funny he did if you
see those little pools to Gentiles I
don't know if you see them I see oak
damage but uh in front of us there's
like little pools of light and you can
get that for health so do that he has
the red pulse yes if people were curious
and asking yes there's the red balls
right here
whoa that makes a weird sound this is my
first time using it last night at the
last minute oh yeah it was it was a one
of those like okay we're gonna go to bed
we don't beat it this turn kind of oh
these little pulses okay not smaller and
you have not no I'm up there's one I
feel like oh there's one up there okay
there there definitely need some weird
spots I guess we could go thirteen
minutes seems okay we started with 15
right after the trap yeah
little walls the light don't forget
those for help
however useful and they give super which
is pretty nice
oh really yep it's like light
restorative light they're still
anomalies keep an eye out for him Bob
Jones says he only got the r8 submachine
gun in close by the way Bob Jones was
one of people who helped me with the
raid last night there's definitely the
one thing I will say that's mild now
granted it is this normal mode and not
hard mode but nope if you don't get a
piece of gear right it kind of feels bad
because you only get three coins instead
which doesn't equate to a actual piece
of gear because a piece of gear costs
twenty coins once you keep the raise so
from the from the vendor I had like
30-something coins I was able to get
three engrams
that's pretty good which is wait thirty
no you shouldn't be able to buy three
it's a it should be should be twenty
four angry I did not have a sixty though
but I got three engrams unless hey I got
one for free do you get one for free
good beginning I got three engrams oh
okay I don't want to tell you but you're
not counting the raid one right or
though no no no I'm talking no no cuz
I'd already gotten the clan one yeah I'm
talking like I went to the raid vendor
and I was able to get three pieces
actually gonna make the last boss a
little bit trickier I feel like because
you see any anomalies or anything now
might be the next area it's just weird
that it keeps telling us that there are
no anomaly detected yeah what's the we
got to protect this goes right and what
is the range on the anomaly that I'm not
positive on I know in watching a video
there was like another the next section
kind of where the servitor is if you've
done Stirling was definitely something
no yeah I almost want to say they gave
more time this week because there isn't
any elemental damage bonus so they know
it's gonna take you a little bit longer
there's a over card change here
somewhere yeah
well that pulse does sound really weird
it does right yeah okay ten minutes left
okay I think swap over my chest please
actually Oh watch out servitors I'll
forget out later
also gonna swap it for my arch foot
okay I got male 8 to death
what's happening
oh boy
yeah
bad oh you want a lot of this strike is
just waiting for things that kind of
sucks
yeah that's the other thing right yeah I
mean we're getting all these leg lights
probably not
that's how I look at it so you guys can
sorry
shanks are actually a problem with
slowdown know if I know with my art like
it damages me cuz they explode I
probably actually want to switch the
Golden Gun after I use the super alright
so we should just leave this guy being
like let's just go yeah it's okay it's
just the life of not having a mic to
tell him what to do
yeah okay yeah we got to go back outside
right yeah I think there's anomalies out
there you can have their house yeah
there has to be so if you see any
looking to start jumping through some of
these lights while we look for anomalies
but there definitely should be some in
weird areas well it says nearby right I
don't like it'll get that little
indicator do they say that yeah we're
moving a little indicator that's so like
anomaly nearby yeah yeah oh I see one
well though I'm not getting the thing
here are you sure that's not it dad I
know that's just a regular oh man
that's mean
yeah Ellis's it is a chest it's probably
okay I just got wrecked by Pike she
didn't like put you know that's a
regular one open world here I don't I
don't like the strike a cool pop event
we have time right now
I guess maybe there aren't any out here
and we'll have to go to the next part
I'm not seeing any yeah I'm not gonna go
to the Decatur we're six minutes right
now
not great great but you know we can it's
fine that one well it's just a bad lease
that man
deal okay
just be careful out of heavy or I would
be doing some more than hopefully gun
what one do I want six shooter cool
he's down again what
Seifer never behind
probably a mistake
yep Easy's down again
that damage I'm also cool thank you
yeah
areum
fool all right four minutes hopefully
there's some anomalies soon this is like
last week all over again well not
knowing exactly what to do to do right
and so some people are thinking we're a
little too low-level no we're just dying
to stupid stuff not knowing that there's
like cuz it's weird because like we're
getting thrown into like doing certain
parties certain parts of the strike but
then there's also like just random stuff
in the world that's like we're not
targeting you know like sniper for
example those behind you now we know I
didn't know that prior there's
definitely anomalies in here okay over
here they're like in these tunnel things
also they glow a bit yeah over here feel
like we didn't get enough from that
first they're definitely not way up
there like we're gaining that much time
how we are we're gaining time okay we're
at free before now we're at like 5:45
okay we see any more oh there's
definitely more one right up there well
gang sniped are we just running through
now or oh shoot
over here I'm trying to see if there's
any more without wasting too much time
don't see you do yep I think that's not
bad I think we're at the boss now yep
are we just gonna fight from the middle
best far right
I think so but he's gonna also be up in
our grill their middle sure true I got a
sore I'm also out of primary which is
kind of a problem yeah we just gotta
keep killing stuff to get this
restorative lights right and then just
and then use supers and or Seabreeze in
what I chain are serious oh man
so there was sort of light slides
because of because yeah so so if I fall
off the plant they might fall off the
platform gosh yeah
one times he should be coming out soon
right six minutes it'll be close close
that's for sure
nope he's coming somewhere I just I have
a sorry yes yes given the business give
him that are two nope just disappear
yeah runs away and it's yeah it's the
raid sword so repetitive slashes could
be back on ammo ammo
oh boy boss is back as well good job up
good I put a grenade next to you to
thank you
I just got picked out of the air we
gotta kill these ads I mean I'm gonna
focus on the Golden Gun Tim did you run
away I'm getting heavy cuz I'm on one
now okay that's fine
I suppose really close to super it was
like no music my boss up something
spawning under that a server there too
I can kind of deal with the Boston come
oh here is
nice right away yes oh boy oh boy
getting the shield off that guy the
servitor
Oh something is wrecking me I'd be the
servitor Oh
boss is back I just got killed
yeah too much stuff grab that grab that
yes yes yes oh boy yeah yeah yeah smart
yep yeah well what the boss is here
though
trying to get him up right now Marius
I'm down I'm trying to hide for my life
because I'm reviving you get over thank
you
is there supposed to be music playing
during this I don't know I feel like yes
yeah it feels great it feels very muted
right now it's like that's the killed oh
boy this is rough that's all you know
there is no there is no prism anymore I
think it was just a weird bug if you
like played early in the day because
like even trials for me this morning are
you guys available
oh I'll be up in five seconds I'm just
gonna chill back yeah there's too much
over there you do have a shank behind
you though oh how did I again oh crap
you spot too huh
coming to you I'm gonna go pick him up
I actually wish prism was on in a way I
don't know maybe we'd be dying soon or
two though feel like we needed more time
- what's his life at I don't know I was
about to ask ya dang all right we'll see
gonna be close
someone says hi Tay yeah hi Corinne he
is at a little bit over a third possible
maybe it with a minute if I can get my
super again but I have finding those
whoa I just killed the server in middle
and gunshots ding I'm getting a static
shock yeah you guys got to kill the
tanks as much as possible we still got a
minute I mean we closed the blight pools
of light start killing these shanks as
they're spawning yeah
grazie I don't know he's in the middle
somewhere
bring him to the grenade he disappeared
again
yep super frustrating because now he
can't come in
I honestly said oh there is I think we
didn't do enough in the beginning to get
a get stuff to get time we're good okay
we're doing the nightfall we just did a
lot of learning there is how I perceive
it so we're given another go should be
fine and we're gonna definitely look for
more anomalies in the beginning because
it only looked like two sets of
anomalies unless we're really unless
we're missing like a set of them because
like one time I did last week's
nightfall without doing one set of rings
and it was exponentially harder because
I lost like we lost like three minutes
not doing that so we'll try again we
actually were close I say if we had
another like two minutes it would have
been fine yeah also usually it's nice to
have our third on the mic so we can kind
of like we missed anomalies okay well
tell like start shooting at me jam if we
miss some cuz like I know we missed some
in the beginning for sure cuz we only
killed like two in that opening area
where it says anomaly detected I had a
good at a pretty good general gist of
that one room because we shot like so I
feel like if we have like eight to ten
in that room we should have probably got
like around eight to ten mm-hmm in that
beginning area so we'll just do a better
job in the beginning area yeah I heard
there's a cheese for this nightfall I
mean I feel like it's probably kind of
hard to cheese this guy a little bit
only because he disappears all the time
so it's like I don't know if someone
knows the cheese great well you could
try and stun him right
with our Strider yeah I guess but I feel
like at some point damage specialist he
just disappeared
he just goes like oh cool I have a new
smoke bomb later cuz I could try like
Ark Strider like stunning all right so
let's go there's an anomaly right here
Jesus no I got that oh you did okay
that's what I got all right cool boobs
asking about max light level it's
actually three fifty fifty I think you
can slowly crawl that way I would say
get on a pike this time John Luke yeah
instead of getting pikes that's probably
fair I'm kind of trying to get ooh
there's one oh nice
they're in some weird spots here I'm
just gonna sort of get this bird's eye
view and sounds good I mean it's easier
to find them in that one room because
it's dark but like in here like out here
in the open it just seems super like
frustrating okay focus on these yeah I'm
doing that right now I'm also looking
for some of these anomalies as well so
when it says that does that mean you're
close to one I think so I think I found
but as far as where and the range I
don't know
nope that was just a [ __ ] like
tricking oh there's one right here's one
way up there got another one okay so
yeah I think we just do a better job
here on this part like we're a 15:53
right now which is like pretty good I
heard the last time dang it will happen
now just there the part of the ships
like had a glowing blue light oh yeah I
got tricked by like a random phantom
light there's one over there
I'm we detected well the good thing is
it seems like they stay in the same spot
so yeah so we'll know even more so
okay all right
yeah definitely keep looking behind you
after you move forward yeah they're like
oh I see one really far away like up top
like underneath a grade-two a box yeah I
switch the scout there's a sniper
sniping you guys from up top he's like
one try this one out
all right that guy's dead
okay anomaly detected I gotta kill this
sniper that Merc this last time there's
one I don't know how far you are I'll
shoot it I see it oh yeah I see it it's
not that one kill another one they said
no no but I'm still getting my anomaly
detected go up here like are we sure
like that actually means like you're
close to one or if they're just around
right relatively within your life okay I
got another one but I'm still getting it
so there's another one here okay because
I've had it go away when I've shot one
still getting it there's another one
cool up nope it went away okay that
might know anomaly detected still I
don't know where though but I mean we're
at 17 minutes now someone just killed
another one I just got that one all
right do we feel pretty confident oh
yeah they're gone there's no more
anomalies no because it says no more it
doesn't say it on the bottom-left
anymore or above you're know what I mean
like previously it was saying anomaly
detected oh that would go away and come
back though as I got closer oh really
okay well oh well there's definitely not
any near here then well then we're
probably good yeah I mean we're 60
minutes but earlier we're at like 13 so
I view that as a win
alright alright let's go
anomaly detected again landing three
strikes within short amount of time
grants or ammo okay so that's how I
don't see oh I see one actually there's
one right there keep looking for him I
guess like you said just kind of every
time you see the few still got a kill
stuff though
oh there's one back there between the
trees and I think we're good I guess I
didn't see any more did you now gonna
hack this okay fifteen way better and
then we're gonna get a bunch of time
from that one room right yeah I feel
like that room gives this already like
it's just tough the first time in like
the shitty thing is there's so many of
these like little blue like lights that
looks like it's blowing like I feel like
they did that there's like at least with
the the dark really dark room like you
can kind of be like okay that's great
yeah I can totally see these things
again I bet they did that on purpose to
give you like a pretty light
right before the boss like here if you
didn't get enough time you're definitely
gonna have here's some free ones for you
feel a little bit better about yourself
before you fight them it's dark what
just like feel better about yourself
yeah that's what I felt about it I'm
still lost
okay it's take so long
I think destiny too is improved since
taking King 77 I think so there are
definitely some huge quality of life
changes there yeah
public events are like way better I feel
like public events are way better the
door like the adventures and stories
stuff please like I enjoyed it more me
too I mean I'm not gonna claim it's like
the best video game forever no no
definitely not but it was definitely
more cohesive it's a cohesive
serviceable story as opposed to the
first one yeah looks like dawn like how
were like serviceable it really is this
I can't argue that I like the lore of
this game a lot I've always liked the
lore a lot of shanks coming yeah I was
like a cool lot of cool like ideas and
concepts that I just think they still
haven't found a good way to like tell in
a good narrative yeah I think they're
getting better though this is like the
REA some of the raid story implications
were actually pretty cool
okay we'll get you to spoilers but yeah
especially how they justify being able
to do the raid multiple times yeah was
actually that was pretty cool exploded
that's up what if the dialogue came do
you pick me up I gotcha gotcha I have
been using my super yeah that's why I
just went to go use it and what's my bad
yeah so long that took three of our 15
minutes of weird changes that I had a
question menu oh yeah and you could like
you know put track certain quests and
objectives and then you would like pop
up on your goats now it doesn't do that
it's all just on the milestones list
which you have to always say it so if
you're like oh hey how far my milestone
you have to pull up okay
the destination let's clean it off we're
about to lose a lot of time here if you
don't okay that's okay what happens when
you have to do both it's just that we're
getting overwhelmed by shanks which do
explode nervous and getting shot up so
all the time we gain just loss DCP
adventures and destiny provide no
progression loop so don't revive now I
mean I think they do just not for
high-level people I think you're meant
to do those adventures more
in numbers historian 86
I do think there's an issue though where
it's really easy to get to level 20
before you even finish the story and is
that up a little bit because then you
hit a wall where it's like you just run
we should just run run
we can't activate this next part we have
to kill Walker right now last time we do
not find any anomalies they're supposed
to I'll keep an eye out now there are
not yeah right in this area
oh boy get away from that now it's just
grabbing pollsters we have 10 minutes
I don't know if that's good or bad
remember better than before how we were
doing last time we're only 60% through
67% through with these pulses they're DC
pieces once you hit a to 60 to 65 public
events are useless they are because of
the soft cap where are the last thingies
to be doing this one did you choose
grab a while ago I might have missed one
oh there's one in the way back oh boy I
think no crazy pointing back there okay
finished
that's just
nine minutes so uh DCP I'm curious now
because we have we just got level three
in our clan which says it provides
better clan rewards are better awards
for doing public events so I wonder if
that negates to some degree the soft cap
you get once the reach to six where are
you going public events I'm heading over
here right to the Walker yeah okay let's
say you like I felt like we just went
the long way around that's okay now
there's no anomalies here yeah heavy I
shanked I don't have a shot
boss alright sniper can I get that guy
he sniped me got him working on a front
left leg there you go
damn much faster all right let's there's
definitely anomalies in here we know
where a lot of them are so I think CCP
was saying I can't wait for anthem
destroy destiny in PvE quality it's hard
to say I mean I'm you know obviously I
would love for it to be great but we've
seen so a little of that game that for
me to say like oh it's definitely gonna
be destiny is like a dude I barely know
so it's really just at this point it's
it's impossible to speculate ideal oh
yeah I'm very excited to see more of
that game I would love for it see
another good Bioware game just to be
honest keep looking for the anomalies
yeah sorry I'm like trying to no no no
you're fine you're doing I'm doing a
good streamer thing and I'm here being
yeah your life what's actually I just
don't want to have to do it no no I'm
with you I'm with you yeah I just got
one so much easier hope you want to bug
me too well see last goodbye our game
what was last could gain by were made um
he's gonna depend on your personal
opinion I guess I like Mass Effect 3
despite its flaws that was 2012 but if
you don't like Mass Effect 3 then
probably 2010 when they made Mass Effect
2 I would say I'd say 2008 2009 early
2010 is probably peak Bioware because
they put out Dragon Age Origins okay we
have like a lot of time
they also put out Mass Effect 2
you know I people like Inquisition I
kind of have a lot of issues of that
game although I that it thinks so if
someone saying you're not gonna be able
to finish this boss in five minutes
laughs yeah you just go without me know
do we can't go without you let's get
back up I was stupid I don't even know
how you're talking about Bioware games
because I'm trying to talk to the chat
don't talk to the chat right now all
right
laser-focused because we just like
seconds sorry about that oh right
because it's attrition I don't think we
gain as much a life back is normal so we
have to pick up the help Oh exotic and
Graham I'm sorry legendary exotic all
right here we go okay all right we have
double the time sweet the last time I
think we can do it I sure hope so I feel
like pretty good yeah but someone wasn't
you can never be too sure well as James
says uh you and you're a good cop bad
cop TV show you think so I guess in
terms of like stream quality Oh like
you're you're worried about the streamer
or the stream I am worried about the
instance yeah we got we got that dynamic
goin
okay okay he's gone for the first time
yep
where that health it shink no whoa hey
guys where's that health that those
bosses back I'm gonna die
okay that's fine it's going way better
than around let's see what I got yeah so
what the Trish in your life comes back
really slowly that's why you have to
kill stuff to get the stupid pools to
get your life back and because we died
we now have to wait like a good amount
of time for how long's your timer
four seconds okay yeah you might as well
just res normal okay
he's on JM right now Sam he's gone he's
gone jerk Thanks
serious serious oh boy
probably no I'm actually okay I must
have waiting to get jmo hurts so bad my
heavy it might benefit did you my yeah
we just gotta keep getting the resort of
Poland's life because it gives you a
full bar of life back so it's kind of
like getting as many drops as we can see
back is he back I don't see him he's
gonna come back here in a second though
after he spawns from shanks it's really
there's that the music's not a shield
server there down shank us down more
shanks cool bosses back
he's gone again good job
I would like some pools of life I see
none can top or not dropping no I see
one now I think it's not the shanks
won't feel - yeah he's justhe's handles
and the dregs are together vandals sorry
areas
this servitor is going to become an
issue oh okay right six minutes six
minutes he's at like half health not bad
not great
I have 15 seconds yep fun times
not really getting a heavy drop ammo
either which is weird
now meaner because usually those yellow
names whatever should be dropping so so
first order of business is kill that sir
trying to put a barrier Oh Oh the
lightning okay cool
getting shocked well yeah I'm trying to
kill you guys should just kill that
servitor first cuz he's just making
everything immune okay
you have a void or no you don't I'll get
rid of it you feel sounds Debbie's good
set there boss
where are you all the way over there
don't worry about me no I'm gonna get
you up because I'm not gonna wait like
20 seconds for you to respawn and
there's nothing around you
all right now I just think cool all
right got my super so I can hit him
again it's good
super is good wine job some restorative
light okay they switch those shock
stuffs at the top now looks like
up
okay a quarter or he disappeared yep
speared I have almost
Oh watch out you're getting mauled right
now whoa Oh
zombie and I'm down where are you it far
I'm far bosses in the middle on Jason
Statham JM JM damn
yeah wasting my super
okay I think boss is on me there was
I died there like all right we got two
minutes trying to think we're trying to
Yolo the boss too hard
plus is really low though yeah how I
wanna yellow him
for JMS can't get you to the shop
oh this is very as there is Marius
Marius state dykes full of life
all right where's yet right in the
middle just keep doing what you're doing
got him yes got a Lincoln green exotic
nice goes dynamite hard work was not in
vain
there it is later ah we did it we did it
good job all right
so that was pretty tough I would say
make sure you get your anomalies killed
we needed that time and also in looking
at that don't stand in lightning know
because that [ __ ] not only hurts but
slows you real bad keeps I kept reviving
me yeah in the lightning we got revived
in the lightning which is like kind of
frustrating cuz it's like well we can't
get anywhere you know why the James G I
think is triple 9 there this nightfall
was a nightmare I think the reason why
this night falls the nightmare is
because it was just the mechanic of this
boss he like goes away like every like X
amount of percentage of damage you do
it's not even like the last night fall
words like okay 30 percent I'm gonna go
do something else another 30 percent I'm
gonna go do something else this is
literally like every 10 to 15 percent
it's like Oh bye bye guys I'm gonna call
my friends to come like I'm gonna give
you lead John Luke alright call I would
call my friends to come over here and
like mess you guys up goop
I got a pulse that's 300 and I think
John Luke got a helm
that's probably decently high so on top
of that not only do we get our nightfall
reward but will also get avala will give
us something as well right yeah voila
and the clan reward oh right clan reward
forget it that's another reason why like
join a clan already just find a clan
that's open you can you can search like
silently open invite and just yeah join
it I mean we made that video a while ago
and I would have hoped that people had
watched that by then didn't know just
like the importance of a clan it's like
you don't even need
necessarily it'll be like buddy-buddy
with everyone you just need to like find
a way into an active one that's like
doing of like doing some of these weekly
yeah kind of like you can just be in
that clan do your own thing and then
every week you'll get like worse hot air
oh I've been getting that too so they
finally fixed the ps4 Pro issue so I can
actually play the game at home now which
is great
but still just like crashes stuff like
that also like Oh games been kind of
buggy that that rate is buggy yeah so
Bob Jones is saying like something you
had mentioned that the level 10 rewards
that we were getting from the raid and
trials could potentially be a bug
especially since it says like hey you're
supposed to get a to 97 to 98 the you
know the reward the raid rewards 10
thing and the trials reward the 10th
power thing that's merrily is apparently
a bug so I will by a friend of mine yeah
and Bob somehow also saw that so yeah I
got this connected to JM 76 I'm trying
to load back in now it's okay though
wait to see what find out John Luke's
got pop in here he's back at Hawthorne
getting his Vanguard tactician you got a
sword and a helmet let's see what take
your nightfall helmet might have been
higher it's weird though so sometimes
with a hawthorn I've noticed that like
my I want to I'll get like an Engram
from her and it'll be like a - like a
luminous one will be like 294 but then
like when you do the Klan one it's like
one light less and I don't really know
why that's the case
the problem with the night ball is
quotes the boss ran away and disappears
into the shadow yeah he's like a ninja
man it's an annoying ninja he's summoned
the Foot Clan to assault us alright cool
so we're a little bit ahead of schedule
what
plans again welcome to do smart my
crucible all right called arms gonna do
some call to arms that'll also get you
clan xp for the week pretty key it's a
this is probably the I think so it's
five hundred I think you can do dry is
so so one in the chat was talking about
the public events how once it gets to
sixty five they are capped yeah but we
just got to rank 3 which says it
increases public event rewards I don't
know if that means you get more if it
actually increases the quality probably
more you try and find out more the thing
though is the 265 is a soft cap so it's
not like it's capped forever that way
it's just you have to get you have to
progress with light and I think when you
get to like 270 plus it will then start
to drop higher-level blues yes and stuff
like that so you will slowly get benefit
it's just like the the fastest way is
doing your your weekly milestones yeah
to get the ones I'm most excited about
is like the Cabal one like number four
is just like you get better stuff for
killing Cabal and it's like during the
raid and stuff but whatever this one
though increases the chance of receiving
reputation tokens when completing night
falls rates and trials it's great yeah
that that's crazy potentially getting
way more tokens at the end of do we have
that what is our level three is it
what's the level three one what's that
no no sorry what is the amount of XP
required for level 3 because it's gonna
exponentially keep going up right and so
we we have level 3 right now no I mean
sorry to 402 for its 100,000 no no
that's the cap I think ok no no that's
how much we need to oh no no you're
right that is the cap yeah so it's one
fit no it doesn't say it doesn't say
what the cap is maybe it is only that is
the we click ok all right
I don't know how much it it doesn't say
specific because last week was 125 to
get us to 3 so like we did 100k the week
before and then this week we've done 25k
which is pushed just at 3 so this is
gonna be like maybe 150 right so it's
gonna take a while to get to that rank 5
though for sure and 5 ring 6 yeah
yeah cuz they like they made it so you
could do exactly like the first week
just to get to 2 you could do exactly
the weekly amount and you'd get to it
but then for last week they made it
where you had like 1/4 left like they
were just like teasing you with yeah
yeah yeah and I get the feeling it
that's just gonna get worse the app
shows level xp needed okay I can pull
that up on my phone well the app shows
it okay that's that's weird that's weird
you know why cuz I guess in their
mindset at least they're from what I
could tell on the screen was that it was
showing you what your weekly a like a
plan oh they're pretty high yeah well it
would maybe go higher because you're
boots have plus five right so be a to
light difference for you whoa it's a
125k according to that so it's gonna
take another week and a half or two
weeks so we'll get it next week yeah so
it didn't exponentially go of that as
what as high as high as I thought it
would so that's kind of cool all right
I'm gonna go turn into my stuff see how
it goes yeah it's only 125 K and thanks
for the tip there Bob and as well as KTM
192 a k appreciate that trying to help
my purple engrams to turn into an exotic
which it hasn't yet and alright so yeah
we could do either or either thing John
Lee Trevor
whatever works yes okay let's see that's
got a brain Graham juice Mexico
don't see him currently he can join on
me if he wants to nice oh so that's not
gonna be as high though right because no
that's very standard one to 86 so that's
the thing so the cap is kind of yeah it
slowly Rises slowly rising remain which
is because you're probably higher than
to 90 you're just probably not wearing
all your iron definitely I'm just what
would you call it like fake fake
leveling yeah with mods basically it
like makes your character
I mean it's so beneficial right because
you need it for like I'm sure the game
still registers it for like the raids
and stuff like that but in terms of like
actual gear drop it'll be not too bad
yeah but it's like thing II just need
one of the problems like okay to
actually get to the appropriate why I
have to wear like I have to like hold a
sidearm or something like something I
just don't care about it
damn our other party member said one of
his purples turned exotic and he got a
302 coal tar it's got some brake dust
nice so we've found just so you know
that the coins that you can buy from her
the fireteam medallions they're actually
really good okay they like really help
my friend said that like if you're doing
the neat like the maps that Kate sells
it on a weekly basis that you probably
want to pop one of those coins because
some people are saying that it's helped
them get an exotic out of those chests
now I didn't get one last weekend right
or lastly you'll have my foot it hopes I
also just buy these every now and then
the fireteam medallions so yeah yeah we
can do heroic events if you want to just
to test that theory we could try one yes
I might as well go to Titan if you're
gonna do it I'll join on you sure sounds
good because this week's flashpoint is
on Titan think that that shitty right
but it's actually not that bad so Titan
only has like three spots it could have
a Titans whole big event on but
apparently since it's just since it is
on Titan and they know that it only
takes like three heroic public events
and you finish your quest which is fast
it's normally like five like on necess
that's heroic
- so I need like clear later Harry
Vickers thanks for stopping by I really
appreciate the kind words hope to see
you next time
cold heart sorry dropping yes Bob I
ain't gone three so yeah whenever you're
oh I'm flying in on you so whenever
you're ready we can go do gas on let's
try some pub events clear up some space
here yeah no worries oh I just got
another error sick jeez
JM was saying - just now he was getting
an error I'm not sure why it's one event
for Titan it's not one event unless I'm
pretty sure I did like three this
morning heroic what for the yes we'll
find out oh so nothing's there yet you
just got a website letting me it's not
letting me launch oh because I bugged
out and the game thinks I'm joining you
[Music]
okay yeah I'm not really sure what's up
with the these hard disk yes yeah kind
of annoying yeah there happen to be once
yesterday thankfully it was right before
we started doing the raid so it did not
happen mid raid so was did you see my
air no I just I didn't read the actual
air I was just asking if that was the
same air you were getting no that's what
pros like something more specific
I'm trying over the name of the error
but mine would like the game just
wouldn't crash and still eat you would
like fries up okay hard lock for a good
like five seconds go black like ten
seconds then pop up the error message
interesting it was like thing really bad
like it seemed like it was damaging my
playstation
level of like hey get rekt one time this
like checkerboard pattern appeared
another time he actually didn't go from
the black so I had to like hard like
shut off my PlayStation more like it was
a bro that sounds horrible alright just
transferring my gear over to my warlock
so I can do these events with y'all and
gain the benefit you know where I
haven't gone since I've beaten the story
I owe the truth be told I haven't gone
to IO or Titan they're the two smaller
planets at the for the now luckily
bungees been smart about sending us to
places like this to do flashpoints yeah
you'll have yeah but I bet you next week
it'll be because it's gone one two three
four so so tight you don't get they've
gone back to you because I have the like
to do the King requests stuff like that
but I oh I know there is like a quest
you can do there but it doesn't get you
in exotic so I was like I don't want to
do that plus I think Asher is the worst
character in this game and I don't want
to talk to oh that guy yeah he's a
little he sucks he weirdo dude it's like
it's like that smartass archetype but
like there's it doesn't say anything
actually like insightful or helpful he's
just an [ __ ] and I don't like him so
I see the public event now is that true
am I making it up let's feel like I saw
the marker for it yeah it's up no it's
gonna be five five minutes yeah it's
fine so what you can do to John Luke is
you we can pull some patrols and those
will give you a personal XP clan XP
that's true and that'll get you like 250
per Patrol as well so I challenge for
some pickup quest ones challenges in the
crucible for reputation bundle yeah
there's a couple of there's a couple
ways I've been I did patrols that also
works
you know what the other thing that
bothers me is what you know like you
have your challenges and not for the
planet but like if you pick up the limo
or anything it basically won't show till
after that which I find frustrating feel
like there should be a way for it to
still trigger I guess not I have max
gonna right now oh you should have
bought weapon parts I should have
I've even doing those weapon part of
weapon wad swaps I have not been doing
that yeah so once you guys get to 280 if
you guys aren't there already one of the
best things to do while you're leveling
to that power level is to buy blue mods
with your glimmer because you're gonna
cap out and then at 280 you'll be able
to trade in three blue mods for a purple
mod which will then give you that fake
light we were talking about plus five
damage plus five armor right cetera et
cetera
yeah fake that light I mean you still
need it for like I said all the mail
feed you technically doesn't so it's
yeah it's just the game doesn't register
the mods as part of your light for
whatever reason for drops in terms of
powerful right which makes sense yeah I
mean because otherwise you're just like
can make it do it really fast by just
faking it
warframe is my heart yeah
there's been a lot of discussion from
people about like warframe races but I
understand why people could feel that
way I mean you could actually walk
around in your ship in warframe so point
to warframe yep
I'm really buying you can do a lot of
stuff in the ship for like going to
missions and right like that's not just
the hub world but it can become part of
your hub world I guess kind of curious
like I wonder if destiny could have just
like that concept I wanted them to like
I was white right that they didn't do
anything more with the ships like I feel
everyone's like do we get to
why'm do we get a control and we at
least get to walk around in them like
something right they gave you a transmat
effect that you could change which is
cool but like relative to everything you
just mentioned right no but the the
Cabal one's really cool have you seen
that one yeah that's the first one I got
now oh nice yeah I have a live one on
right now so like when you come back
your high V oh dude also my laptop that
was feeding us chat died so Oh died I
know yeah I don't know so I will have to
look at my phone in here in a second let
me pull that up run this a safe spot and
pull that up I apologize guys it said an
hour and a half I swear to you it
started this game so I kind of believed
it like a pork shat on my phone close I
think we'll just do this event maybe
like another one if there's another one
that's close and then kind of call it a
successful scream exhibit in two tries
we didn't exactly know what we were
doing the first time around so that's
what I'm gonna go that's uh I think
that's fair forgiven yeah he's on a
Titan sesmar bear what these guys are
kind of newbies Yeah right it
I take offense to that I don't know how
you classify UV and destiny though
well is it fine it's like a new player
so light is it by skill level sure we're
definitely not newbies new since our
life I've been playing destiny for
really bad with the Rockets I don't use
a rocket launcher see what happens when
you get used to using Gjallarhorn your
whole life you don't really have to try
because if this does everything you need
it see for you okay
yeah we'll just get that later all right
here we go yep
you target the guy he's on the bottom
rea mean
smart Jan oh I got a purple off that
captain is it working hold on let me pop
a coin a Papa coin I do see a purple
drop he's down
oh did we get the other book did you
grab it yep okay cool
yeah you can start damaging with
all right the other day on my way sorry
I love my floaty warlock jump
did you end up driving that other ball
to put in I didn't grab the third one
now someone did Oh jam grabbed it nice
that's been happening this today
recently what Wow how can we have
another Walker we have a third Walker
what is what is going on do you not see
that
oh no same one okay they kill we didn't
kill the first one I thought we killed
the other one holy crap
I was gonna say that like that a shank
that's been coming out that doesn't
normally happen if you like but oh I got
punted feels good
but yeah that shank is like a high-value
target for some reason has been spawning
geez
oh come on what did you die again oh by
the blast
flame I'm gonna chill for a second
scorch cannons down
okay I lied I died with it hello there
hello
Jesus
Oh was it because he went for the shank
that captain hurts so bad okay all right
shank you got just kidding Mertz
hilarious actually
all right a few captains
I got em I killed
I really should just pick up a score
scan Jim
oh yeah
come on come on
so I think pop the coin and we have
level three so let's see if it actually
makes a difference well sorry to tell I
mean exotic the coin oh I got an exotic
did not get exotic uh you got a purple
on two blues though that normal or do
you think that that's better than normal
I don't always I don't normally get an
exotic so that's definitely it okay
exotics can happen there's another one I
don't really only get two three three
jobs I've seen up to four drops with the
coin yeah but so do you think that's the
coin or do you think that's the the clan
thing that's the thing cuz you pop that
coin it's hard to tell
he's playing a hunter right now bro you
guys asking oh and yes if we had the
right element for said Ark boss or
whatever we would shoot it
polic that's why he felt like we were
newbies because we weren't using the
right element against certain types of
monsters
oh but that makes sense yeah we know to
do heroic to get better keep dropping
also we are level 3 now with the clan so
technically we're supposed to get their
jobs in general also I popped the what
is now kind of the three of coins the
bright paragon what you could buy for 50
bright does so we have everything - like
where else yeah we have like multiple
like XP and like item find if people
know what I'm talking about I don't find
drop there's actually a chest right here
if you guys want it another Brian Graham
for doing okay so they don't have
another one for doing the raid this week
I'm writing that probably mean the right
thing powerful yeah initial doing it
once it seems like it doesn't make the
trigger the raid and then no show up
maybe but that's a good point yeah it's
not it's not a repeatable in that so I'm
gonna like it alrighty I'm gonna look
for a patrol outside perhaps
man ever since I had got that it finally
got the instant sparrow on one of my
characters it feels really weird to not
have it's gonna character it is so good
I didn't even realize I had it at first
I was just like oh wow like yeah I'm
getting Sparrow way faster
well yeah either way thank you guys all
for tuning in we're playing dusty to
obviously second week of our weekly live
stream of Jesse - called Destiny's
children we stream on Tuesdays the UK
wonder what I get what again coin
apparently this chess is helped by the
conservators I've never done this oh
she's interesting I've done this yeah I
just said I didn't aah
it's like that's harder than killing one
high-value target all right sighs in
five seconds the public event oh maybe I
could rally the frag and get another
super news do you know how you know how
to trigger this one right yeah yeah
Senna book ad kill the queen or though
which is
okay
oh sweet baby
okay down
so my wife she just jumped away I have
to stand back on my another one can you
stand on the pad that's why I had to get
off the pad
hi I'm like you guys by myself
come on
so wake up already
oh yeah we do it slowly and then we did
or no actually no we just got shoots a
little fish are the other all away
where's big boy
are there two guys there are totally two
guys I remember that yeah I think it's
because it's like it must be this week's
thing because it's on that's why I like
that server I was telling you about
which showed up too and that was weird
oh this is always like a light show oh
yeah get hard light out and just
Oh
Palpatine uh well he can't stand where
he wants to smash you that guy reminds
me of alikoum I'm taking alright good
luck on your jobs
maybe you'll get any job this summer
full ready for that hot exotic that
you're gonna get no nothin JM is gonna
get that I'm gonna get back-to-back now
there's no way absolutely no way I hope
you went to go pick it up it's right
here buddy okay is there any other spot
we can go to if you do one more one more
and then you'll be gone there you know
it would have to be a sirens watch
eventually yeah nothing yet yeah but
pretty good so far yeah trying to check
up on you guys in the chat I'm like my
cellular phone because my laptop died
Paulo geez for that okay we definitely
don't score games Jay boy your boy on
the run that's not what we do we just
play you and me yeah oh do not they
weren't happy about our gameplays and
then they he says that they hope that we
don't swore games but either way we
don't score game so oh because of the
whole just dying and stuff it happens
you know like sometimes you know like
I'd like to see people do it do what we
do too you know and then have them
experience I'd like to think I'm average
against like I represent like the
average the more the most that's the the
normal player yeah like I don't the
majority of the demographic how about
that yeah I'd say I'm like slightly
above average when it comes to like my
my skill level and games mm-hmm which
honestly I mean I don't like I said I
don't review her score games but if I
did I feel like in terms of my skill
level I represent them vast majority of
people the world
so I feel pretty okay and I feel I feel
okay in my in my abilities to review a
game yeah but I do not so if you're not
my skills even even easier right not
having to do it but either way I
appreciate you chatting with us and
sharing your feelings with us
mmm but we will also defend ourselves
exactly don't we're not gonna say
nothing for free here take that lying
down there is a El Capitan up sailing it
right by his head we're done
this guy trying to shoot rockets at this
guy there you go
the vest was last week and then I Paul
when I whipped like three rockets in a
row that felt real good what's that
scream yeah nice it was like I keep
trying to like aim for where he's gonna
be yeah next one starts in two minutes
over it sirens watch okay yeah I'm gonna
just I was like in the menus shot oh is
it because we you can just cancel that
mission if you hold down trying
oh is it one of those run two of things
I got that I finished the thing tried to
like get off my Sparrow Sparrow and then
jump and I just like didn't make it
that's alright alright finish that guy
so now you can fast travel if you're
trying to I'll just run it's not I think
they'll see me I don't die just trying a
fast travel it's crazy how you can fast
travel faster than you can pick up what
your patrol though right
apparently YouTube chat says angry girl
wasn't a big fan of game days review
yeah they were saying together to six I
mean I can see it you know I think this
game has a very specific a style of play
if you're not into that I don't think
you'll you'll like it you know but in a
review assuming he had to review
destined one right so that's why didn't
he give destiny one I do not know so
right chat since you're bringing it up
what did he give destiny won right cuz
they didn't view that as a better game
because that's really awkward if he gave
destiny one a better score than destiny
- sure right we can both agree I would
agree so - is better than just agree
with that if he liked destiny one and
doesn't like destiny - then I guess I'm
confused and now curious what his
because I would then be knocking the
game because it's too much like I don't
know I'd have to watch a review well
like you know what I mean like
but if he didn't like logic if he didn't
like the first one yeah I can see him
being like still don't like this one
absolutely that that would make a lot of
sense to me yeah I don't know I have not
seen this video I can't really say
that's fine I like anger Joe I think he
makes really good videos very long
though which again not a bad thing it's
yeah hard to sometimes be like I'm gonna
sit down and watch the 30-minute review
yeah but I mean those are like reason
right I mean if you can oh no no I think
he justifies those 30 minutes I think
yeah uses it well yeah not trying to
criticize but with just like the
attention span of like the internet I
guess it's kind of it is kind of hard to
be like oh there's a 30 minute video you
should watch his whole review but you
know it gives enough people who watch it
I mean he gets queens of use on this
video so obviously a lot of people yeah
willing to put in that time
I know you streams from time to time to
you
all right so this should hopefully be
your Alaska
Oh
yeah the only thing I'm not that I'm
kind of sad about is Titan the only
pretty much has two types of public
events so there's not as much diversity
no it really isn't
but message from the EDC oh that's like
agree I don't know no sounds like maybe
four I will say that is a knock against
this game would be that the air like the
the different planets I thought the
first game had like a better like I
wanted to go to all of them in the first
game yeah this one I'm very much like
etz in essence and then Titan I'm like
okay with and then I oh I have like a
zero and she's never going but is it
because of the MPC though part of its
the NPC the other part of its like it's
just so small yeah I don't know it's
just like for whatever reason I don't
really feel interested in going there
maybe like if they give me a reason
my leg I think of you know the first
game it's like oh yeah like Cosmodrome
the Moon Venus like you know they were
miss Venus baby I went to all those you
know very frequently
Mars Mars was probably the worst first
game there was like nothing to do on
Mars
they had to save all the Cabal for now
yeah like it was like it was just a lot
of it was a very big it was also very
empty and I remember Mars being kind of
a release interesting and it was like
one color right yeah and visually you're
like oh that's Mars a lot of red first
guys down Oh No
like how I go guys score scanning
still one up actually there's two of you
guys
oh geez yeah it's over there
exploding once the shank show up again
oh the big shank yeah I feel like it did
that last week though I wonder if they
patch something in yeah I don't remember
doing that last week but that's cool I
like kind of like it it adds a little
bit of a twist on the right the public
events and kind of makes it harder I
think they're definitely getting better
making that stuff like if your son who
doesn't like the repetitive grinding
it's probably not gonna you know do much
too much for you but I think for those
that are okay doing it they're doing a
good job like trying to make give them a
little twist each time it was just like
okay you're gonna do the exact same time
and we finished our milestone more gear
for you all right let's go check out
that gear and then hopefully you get
this hot did you not get anything good
now boom got one drop I don't know if
that clam three things working right
[Music]
still feels random guys still feels
random the token once more interesting
because what is it a guaranteed or is it
just like what do you that and justice
increasing the chance I receive yeah but
it definitely helped I mean like you
might as well use it though you know
what I mean oh yeah absolutely
feel like it's like a three of coins
okay to the tower all right I killed the
duty
oh wait he does not count apparently no
he does it seizes the backbone I always
forget his tresses and
[Music]
all right cool
you want to just head back to this house
check your gear and follow the stream
good old streamer stream let's do it
that was pretty successful yeah fun time
thank you guys all for tuning in
we'll see what John Luke gets if he gets
lucky he gets an exotic being from a
purple that happen to jam that would be
awesome
alright let's see he gave destiny 106 as
well so the same for him okay I feel
like that makes sense if he didn't like
destiny 1 I was hoping for it too
didn't this was all from Amish war
machine thank you for other information
he said would have given D - I think
this Angry Joe would have given D to a 7
if now for microtransactions and not
getting a goddamn sparrow until near
level 20 however I my counter to the
whole Sparrow thing even though it's
annoying is that I think what they
learned what Bungie learned was people
were just spelling through this
beautiful world that they had created as
a story and like stuff they're just
skipping stuff right that that you know
obviously they wanted you to see and go
through right and so by at least forcing
you through your at least your first
playthrough because you could transfer a
sparrow if you want on your second
character you would at least have to
kind of go through the world it's kind
of like World of Warcraft where you
don't get your mount until like later on
right you get a you do get a slower
amount but you don't get a mount for a
little bit you run around a lot yeah and
I'm not necessarily mad at that
no I first isn't too mad at and I think
that is exactly I've ever called there
was a tweet that said like hey just
enjoy the you know world and so I think
he pretty much nailed it there that was
a reason why they did that
what do you think about
microtransactions I never liked
microtransactions and things sure I
it doesn't necessarily detract the game
for me yet I can run into a point where
I've felt necessary yeah spend money but
I don't particularly care for loot boxes
and games and I'm bummed that this game
has loot boxes I'm not
my foxes you mean the Brighton grams
right yes they're basically loot boxes
they're randomly boxes out
I'm not surprised though because you
know this is activision yep owns
Blizzard mm-hmm
you know overwatch very much popularize
blue boxes I'd say they're not NCS you
know I'd say those two games are kind of
very much popularized that I think call
a duty might be having I don't actually
boxes but it doesn't surprise me that
they're in the game I'm more just kind
of disappointed that they're in the game
I'm not really angry though okay uh I
have two opinions about it now for me
personally I don't care about the
microtransactions because for the most
part sans the coin that we just popped
right right it doesn't affect the game
it really only affects how you appear
now sure you could argue that like maybe
getting a sparrow from the Brian Ingram
that like insta sparrows is a benefit
compared to someone that just has a
normal sparrow but you got a sparrow
regardless right you get a ship
regardless so I think all of that's
cosmetic and I think it's fine if you
want to spend the money go ahead I
actually think it's not as bad because
you can't get bright engrams by playing
the game now you get them slower right
because it's only when you level sure
sure obviously most other games like
overwatch overwatch yes so like that
stuff doesn't necessarily bother me
personally as much so the second point
was the bright engrams and being able to
earn them
yeah so that's where I am on that part
of it like I can kind of see why people
kind of get upset about it but I think
if you're somebody influence the game
though no it'll look good not pay to win
it doesn't but I think if there's
somebody who just has a general disdain
for maybe the way companies sort of
treat their consumers to try and get
more money out of them it's sort of like
a like a point of pride or something
just to cut like like it said you're
just kind of taking a stance on it
because it's like yes it doesn't affect
the game but these companies know that
people want that stuff and are you know
kind of abusing that factors to try and
get more money out of them so in that
regards like if you look at it that way
it is
like you can't help but be like oh
that's kind of sleazy right because you
know that they know people want that
right yeah and I guess the other big
point to was the which is like the one
of the hottest points of contention I
feel like with destiny two chasers
yep shaders which is another thing that
angry Joe brought up again for me
personally it doesn't necessarily bother
me but I can see why it's kind of
annoying and frustrating I held off a
lot of my better shaders for later
because I knew that I was gonna be
changing gear a lot I feel like I got
closer to my quote-unquote final form in
which case I would then use the shaders
on the gear I really liked now I do
understand that like people want to just
use those shaders on stuff and get them
back you got to use though first in the
first game like I think it's more the
fact that by like the custom I like the
custom element customize the ability to
do individual pieces sure sure although
your gun yeah no that's cool I'm not
saying that is we're just saying that if
you have the shader you should just own
it and be able to put it on it yeah I
think it's the fact that people were
like hey how come the system where I had
the shader and it was fine now it's been
changed where it's this consumable that
clearly feels like a thing just to make
money like it it just feels like I guess
I don't know maybe I don't think it's
the worst thing about this game um you
know it's a point of contention Oh
exotic Booya
I already have that that's a 301 though
but that's a 301 oh so it is yeah so
like it's not gonna I wouldn't put it
into that chest now I can get rid of
this although wait what actually no it's
not worth it because that's a 296
essentially what the 301 is essentially
a 296 the reason why studio 1 is because
it has a little modifier but you can
make your 300 a 305 if you just put a
purple mod into it if you wanted to I
could yeah but you don't have a purple
why now so go by mods yeah I should go
by that so that you can turn in for a
purple and I should just get rid of this
tangles I guess dismantle goodbye
people would be upset about the same I
don't know I guess it just depends on
the person right I feel like some people
are gonna be really upset about that and
then some people are just saying yeah
whatever
again yeah I think it largely comes of
big use like or your feelings on the way
companies treat their consumers and you
know that is a personal point of
contention you know some people don't
care other people like angry Joe and and
Jim sterling I know like that is a point
of like that is a big factor for them
when they when they are talking about a
game is loot boxes microtransactions in
games that you're already spending $60
does it feel like you're you know
abusing your consumers to try and get
more money out of them I'm like that's
that's a big thing for those kinds of
people I guess yeah I don't know maybe
it's the naive part of me and it
probably is I just feel like if you want
to spend money on the on the bright
engrams spend money I'm not gonna spend
money on them I'm not I'm just gonna
play the game you get bright dust from
breaking down shaders you get you know I
mean like I don't know but but maybe I'm
the problem
maybe I'm because like a lot of people
are probably like me that don't care but
then there are the people that are like
whales and I don't know maybe I'm not
helping the cause I guess but so what
should these monster so you can turn you
can transfer turn in for all those right
now so basically all of those are
eligible for you you can click through
all of them oh and you'll get them all
so as long as you have the blue mods
you're gonna get these purple mods these
purple mods can go on multiple pieces of
armor they will kind of fake your light
as I had mentioned they could go on your
weapons your energy weapons so like your
290 energy weapons will be like 3
something cool yeah so I don't know
that's kind of been a fun little stream
there guys thank you guys all for tuning
in we'll be back next Tuesday of course
to do the nightfall again I think that
it's in the schedule I should look that
up so I could tell you what that
actually is since they have plotted out
far in advance oh I think is it next
week that the the factions come back I
think dead orbit in them are on their
way back that was scheduled that I'm
gonna put
your call has like a big room over where
Kate is but you can't actually do
anything yeah I don't know if it's a 926
yeah faction rally begins so we'll have
the factions back next week
nightfall next week will be the pyram
pyramidion pyramidion with torrent and
warp zero warp zero our I could pull
this up let me throw one sniper I try to
screen cap this part of it I said that
they can see the schedule for next week
I'm just gonna be a little jank here
move some stuff around see oh crap
technically tzer's in there - yeah
somewhere well that's that definitely
didn't work for some reason
so yeah that's zero will obviously be
back to this coming weekend or this week
on Friday so you guys should check that
out too really trying to get this we
should have always had the schedule do
keen wit to be honest but right I am now
doing it live I like tight no I don't I
think if we okay we'll probably back in
a second that's by stream no it was not
the wrong button
all right we're back what did you think
I what did i do I don't know some our
streaming program crashed because I was
trying to take a screen shot take us
here I'm gonna try it again if it
crashes don't I'm saying goodbye dance
but I have to tase gonna try it try to
see